here is the face of a pedophile whose
crimes have traumatized a schoolgirl for
Life 53 year old butcher Andrew Miller
and here is the same person identifying
as Amy George seen in February learning
a youngster into his car while dressed
as a woman thinking she was safe she
accepted a lift home before the Predator
locked the child in his bedroom for
hours subjecting her to repeated sex
attacks
today Miller admitted it all the court
hearing the child only escaped and phone
999 after her abuser fell asleep
the judge here described these crimes as
abhorrent and every parent's worst
nightmare sentencing will come in August
but there has been a major route here in
Scotland about where to retain trans
prisoners that led to a policy change
meaning their birth gender overrides
everything Miller will therefore be
detained in a male prison the Scandal
earlier this year surrounded trans
double rapist Isle of Bryson being
temporarily detained in a woman's prison
first Minister Sky News questions
Scotland's first minister in light of
this fresh case oh first of all can I
say that this is a gut-wrenching case
heartbreaking
cannot think of the trauma the victim
and the family of the victim in fact the
community
are going through I can confirm of
course that Andrew Miller is being held
in a male president but I can't see
which one and I can't go into the
details well he continued to stay in a
male prison well again this is a live
case the sentencing is still to happen
so I can't comment any further but of
course he is being held in the real
estate but can you realize that he will
not be moved to a women's prison I
cannot come in a life case you should
know that political deja vu in a
polarizing issue as Andrew Miller Amy
George prepare for a long period behind
bars Conor Gillis Sky News Edinburgh